[Music]
hey there i'm cameron and welcome to
stylecraft this is a bonus video for you
so this video uh is what you see on
screen here
it's something where i made i took
advantage of repetition which we've
learned about in previous weeks and i
created this
3d
box thing i call it uh stacking boxes
and i just want to show you guys really
quickly how i made this
um and this i'm going to break down a
little bit differently i'm just going to
show you the project i had
and kind of just step through it and
show you how i actually created this
instead of starting from scratch i'm
just going to kind of work backwards and
show you uh what was involved in this
project so what you're seeing here is
the version i posted on
instagram
and it's just
a loop as you can see on my timeline
this is a pre comp that i've got set up
to loop
um one two three four five times over
the course of almost 10 seconds
um and i found that
where it ends here was a good looping
point to go back here to the beginning
so
this is it pretty simple but it looks
pretty cool so let's go into the
pre-comp
and inside the pre-comp it's pretty
simple as well it's
a cinema 4d file with an adjustment
layer and a background so if i back up
and start with just the background the
background is just solid
it's a dark green green lime solid
and a lot of times i like to work with
blacks that aren't 100 black sometimes i
do work with 100 black or 100 white in
this case
it's um in the green spectrum and it's
very dark but if you were to
look
there's 100 black and here's my original
greenish black so
that was important because if this was
100 black it wouldn't look as good
with these
solids back here in my opinion
so
i've got the background and then i've
got this 3d layer
that uh if i open it up in
cinema 4d
is this right here
um and just to jump back really quickly
you'll also notice that this composition
is 1080 by 1080 24 frames per second i
have been building compositions at 1080
by 1080 lately because of instagram and
when i built this i knew i wanted to
post
this to instagram
specifically
which is why i built it at 1080 by 1080.
so back in cinema
this composition is also
1080 by 1080. if i click on my settings
right here
you'll see that it's 1080 by 1080. it's
also 24 frames per second
a total length of 48 frames which you
see down here so it's two seconds long i
also taught you that in a previous
lesson you have to also change your
project settings in cinema 4d and the
project settings are under edit
project settings
and it's changed to 24 frames per second
as well here
so back in after effects since this is
48 frames long
i kind of played around a little bit and
i found that every
12 frames having this uh animation on
top of itself
uh seemed to create a perfect loop for
me so this was just trial and error of
i started with you know zero
like if i was to like line these all up
this didn't loop very well to create
this kind of stacking box effect
um i could have deleted some of these
layers and had like you know just
three here
going
but i found that uh
was this total one two three four at a
time
looked a little bit uh more interesting
to me so that's why these are stacked
every 12 frames
back in cinema
really simple here all i did is i
created a cube
which is under create object cube
or you can click right here and create a
cube
and if i do
that you'll also see that the cube here
has a filet
enabled and it has a radius of 25 and a
subdivision of 25 this is kind of just
personal taste so if i turn the original
off
go back to the one i just created by
default fillet is or maybe it's fill it
i have a tendency to pronounce words
wrong a lot of times so i think it is
fillet actually so if i
click fill it you can see here that's
what it looks like
but to get the dimensions right i also
did 500 by 50 by 500 so
let's go back here it defaults to 200 by
200 by 200 so let's go 500
by 50
by 500.
there we go
so that's just a cube
fill it turned on it makes these kind of
curved edges
it defaults to 25.
i did play around with some different
numbers here i think 25 is as high as it
goes maybe
25 worked
and
you'll notice
when i change it from five
if you watch right in here you'll see it
smooth out just a little bit so 25
right in here
smoothes out just slightly so that
worked for me as well
i believe that was all i did with the
cube
so the next thing i did
was i created a new material that i
dropped on this cube
super simple it's one material here it
is
all i did to create this material was i
went to create
load material preset broadcast
materials abstract two sides blue and
green
there it is
so that was the material
i then um
kind of tweaked it slightly as you can
see here here's the original one i used
and i believe what i did was
it was color
and
transparency here i think i just changed
the color i changed it to more of a red
which you know based on the final image
there's some color correction here you
can see the red going on
but you know if i was to stick with the
original just straight up blue and green
that's pretty cool as well i'm gonna go
ahead and turn on interactive render
region
[Music]
and that's what that looks like
so that's just as cool in my opinion
i've also got
just to show you a simple light in the
scene so this is without the light okay
just if you were just to have this box
drop the material on that's what it
looks like and it's not as interesting
right but by adding a light
that uh creates a lot more interesting
highlights and specular
uh information here and along the edge
here which makes it that much more
interesting to look at
so all this is
is it is an area light which i tend to
use quite a bit of
um
default to 100
it's 100 white i think these are all
defaults so to create the area light if
i was to turn that guy off
is just go up here to light
or create
as well light
and you've got light spotlight target
light area light a few different lights
some of these aren't going to show up in
your version
if you're on cinema 4d lite
but uh area light is there
so there it is i just
raised it up here
and then i just rotated it i don't think
you even have to rotate i always seem to
think that you know the light has to
face the object but that's the same look
as with it well it's slightly different
so there's a dark line so
rotate the light it's essentially just a
big square that just lights your scene
right so if i jump out of here
there's the top view and there's my
square i can actually
drag the sides out
like so i'm making a much bigger light
and it does change the look of you know
my scene here it's much
a lot more highlight specular going on
on the
image
on the block
so go back to how it was there it is
and
at this point all i had to do then was
just animate my cube
moving up
right
and that's just under coordinates i set
a keyframe for y
i drug it down somewhere in here
clicked there's the keyframe
went to the end of my timeline and
because the light was sitting right here
i just drug the cube right below the
light
and that gives the illusion because it's
so close to light it's not being lit
or you can just barely see it so it
almost looks like it kind of fades out
right
so if i play this
there's my animation and i talked about
this in the week that we talked about
form where you can right click on this
animation show f curve
cinema 4d defaults to the spleen with
the keyframes and i just want this to be
linear because i am looping it and i
just wanted a constant motion right of
the boxes
if we go back to that loop
i mean you see here the boxes they're
not starting slow and moving up and
slowing down it's just a constant rate
of speed right so i want that in cinema
4d so i just highlight both keys and i
click on linear right here
so if i play it now
just a
linear move from bottom to top
the last thing i had to do
was
add a tag which we've talked about
in
one of the lessons this week actually
adding we talked about adding an
external compositing tag well this time
all i'm doing to this cube
is i am adding
a cinema 4d tag
display
and what a display tag does
is if i click on these i can turn these
on and i'm going to turn on visibility
that's about the only one i ever really
uh do much with
sometimes i do
use enhanced opengl
but most of them is visibility and this
is just like a fade in and out so i can
set this to zero
you can't see it i can set a keyframe
and then i can move forward in my
timeline
to maybe somewhere in here and say at
this point it's 100
opaque and i set another keyframe
and what i've found i don't know if
there's a workaround there's probably a
work around this but because
there is a
display tag here
when we're working in the viewport at
least with the cinema 4d
basic render you can't see the object
until the first frame passed
a zero value which is kind of strange
but if i
render this like you're seeing here it's
not on
it's starting to fade on
putting on more
and here it is at 100
and then i think i went a couple of keys
uh forward and i set another keyframe at
0 100
and then went to the end and said okay
we're back to zero
and
by doing those very few simple things
i got my default
uh render which was this guy right here
if i render this out
so here he is fading in and that light's
sitting right there so it kind of looks
like it's fading out but it's it's
fading out and it's also the light it's
getting so close to the light that is
getting darker at the same time
and
then i went in and i changed it to add
so that there was some transparency
then i loop these
so that they're every 12 frames and
that's what it looks like here if i
change these back to normal
it's not quite as interesting
there's the normal mode
that was cool but with add much more
interesting
and then the very last step in after
effects is
i created a new adjustment layer and i
added some effects
and those effects are right here
of course i started with my chroma warp
subtle warp very subtle effect you can
you know see it mostly on the edges here
so i turned that on i did a very soft
glow which is right here in the middle
i also added some
noise from after effects this is
built-in noise it's uh
set to a five percent noise very low
value so off on
you probably can't even see it
on the screen that you're watching but
without and width you can really see in
the edges over in here and here and then
the final effect i added was a
third-party plug-in that i
use quite a bit of it's called fresh
lift curves
and it's a
it's a curves plug-in that's just very
powerful to use
i've used this guy for years
i can't remember how much this guy costs
i don't remember it being very cheap but
it's worth it for the power
of editing curves inside of after
effects so i added that and it's a very
subtle effect here as well just boosting
up some of the
the
darkness of the shot which i tend to
produce shots that are very dark and i a
lot of times have to boost
uh the levels well
you could have easily done this with the
curves that's built into after effects
and in fact the newer version of after
effects has some really powerful curves
adjustments built into the lumetri
uh color correction plug-ins so that's
definitely worth checking out it's very
cool uh power in the curves plug in
there so
that's it that's how i created uh this
pretty cool loop here
turn this back on and just show you one
more time
that's my stacked boxes loop that i
posted up on instagram
um
simple workflow i put it together pretty
quickly
sometimes the best work that people
respond to is the stuff that just gets
thrown together very quickly and you
don't have to think a lot about it
sometimes like me personally i over tend
to overthink my designs and by the time
i've reworked them and reworked them
they're not as interesting anymore so
uh glad you guys found this one cool and
hopefully you got something out of this
little bonus video about how i used
repetition to create stacking boxes
that's all i got for you today
talk to you real soon see you guys bye